i've been thinking i really want elon
musk to produce the test like
i i really
am sort of serious that these tests are
simple to make but we've been using like
machines to make them that have been
around for a long time
scale is an issue right now
kind of really it's the eua process and
getting the companies to be allowed to
market in the us that's the issue but
let's just say scale is the issue and
one company wants to make 20 million
tests a day
these aren't that hard like we we should
be able to do that we just need a faster
machine a better machine yeah and a
quicker one and a few folks like you
mentioned know how to solve that problem
yeah i've had a lot of discussion with
uh with tesla folks you know with with
people that used to work a test like jim
keller
about how to make stuff much cheaper
much better that's basically what tesla
is world-class at and
it's like okay
does this
thing have to cost a thousand dollars no
it can cost ten dollars right and let's
figure out how to manufacture it those
those those folks are like the best in
the world they're doing that
you